the woolly gray backs of its flocking
houses which are fragrant treatment a
fragment of his medieval ramparts
enclosed here and there in an outline is
scrupulously circular as out of a little
town in a primitive painting to live in
cambria was a trifle depressing like its
streets whose houses built of the black
and stone of the country fronted with
outside steps capped with Gables that
projected long shadows downward were so
dark that one had as soon as the Sun
began to go down to draw back the
curtains in the sitting-room window
streets with the solemn names of saints
for the windows streets with the solemn
names of saints not a few of you figured
in the history of the early lures of
Combray the roofs and a lair the ruse a
joke in which my aunt's house stood the
roof Samuel God which ramp pasture fence
and the Rue to set us free until which
the little garden gate opened and these
Combray streets exist in so remote a
part of my memory painted in colors so
different from those that now adorn the
world for me that all of them and the
church the towered above them in the
square seem to be now more unsubstantial
than projections of my magic lantern and
a time to feel that to be able to cross
the rue de santa clara again to engage a
room in the Rue de la Sol in the old
hostelry of the was or flushing from
whose basement windows roses snow love
cooking which rises still in my mind now
and then just as intermittent and warm
would be to secure a contact with the
beyond more marvelously supernatural
than it would be to make golos
acquaintance and to chat with Geneva
Genevieve de bravo my grandfather's
cousin my great aunt with whom we used
to say with the mother of an to water
limit lien--a who sends her husband's my
uncle top
his death had gradually declined to
leave first hambre thinner house and
hungry than her bedroom and finally her
bed and who now never came down but lay
perpetually in an indefinite condition
of grief physical exhaustion illness
obsessions and religious observances her
own room looked out over the Rue sanjog
which ran a long way father to the end
to the grandpa as distant as distinct
from the peak lay a green space in the
center of town where three streets met
and which monotonous and grey with the
three high steps of stone before which
before almost every one of its doors
seem like a deep furrow cut by some
sculpture of Gothic images in the very
block of stone out of which he had
fashioned a crush or Calvary my ass life
was now practically confined to two
adjoining rooms in one of which she
would rest in the afternoon while there
while they air the other there were
rooms of that country order which just
as in certain clients whose tracks of
air or ocean are illuminated presented
by myriads a protozoa that we cannot see
fascinate our sense of smell with the
catalyst boulders springing from their
own special virtues wisdom habits and
whole secret system of life invisible
super abundant and profoundly profound
immoral which their atmosphere holds
sustained it smells natural enough
indeed and colored by circumstances air
as are those of the neighboring country
side but already domesticated humanized
confined an exquisite skillful limp and
jelly blending all the fruits of the
season that I've left the orchard for
the store room smells changing with the
year but replenishing domestic smells
which compensate for the sharpness of
the hoarfrost with the sweet say
warm bread smells lazy and punctual as a
village clock roving smells steadfast
smells heedless and Provident linen
smells morning smells pious smells
rejoicing in a piece that brings only an
increase of anxiety and a pro zenus that
serves as a deep source of poetry to the
stranger who passes through their myths
without having lived among them the heir
of those rooms was saturated with a fine
bouquet of a silent so nourishing so
succulent the item that I could not
enter them without a sort of greedy
enjoyment particularly on those first
warnings chilly still of the Easter
holidays when I could taste it more
fully because I had just arrived there
hungry before I went in to wish my aunt
good day I would be kept waiting a
little time in the outer room where the
Sun a wintry Sun still had crept into
warm itself before the fire lighted
already between its two brick sides and
plastering the room and everything ended
with the snow of soot maybe the room
like one of those great open hearts that
one finds in the country or one of the
canopy mantelpieces in old castles under
which one sits hoping that outside it is
raining or snowing hoping even for
catastrophic deluge to add the romance
of shelter and security to the comfort
of a snug retreat I would take a few
steps for the preview to the stamp the
velvet armchairs which one always draped
in a crocheted anti messica anti mascara
while the fire baking like a pie that
like a pie the appetizing smells with
which the air of the room was thickly
clotted where's the dewy and sunny
freshness of freshness of the morning
had already raised and started to set
pump them and glazed fluted them smell
them into an invisible on palpable
country kick an immense puff pastry in
which barely waiting to savour the
Krusty a more delicate more respectable
but also dryer
smells with a cupboard the chest of
drawers and the patterned wallpaper I
always returned with an uncontested
gluttony to bury myself in the ordinary
ruinous resonance dull and adjustable
and fruity smell of the flowered quilt
in the next room I could hear my app
talking quietly to herself she never
spoke saving low tones because she
believed that there was something broken
in her head and floating lose their
which she might displace by talking too
loud but she never made remain for long
even went along without saying something
because she believed it was good for her
throat and that by keeping the blood
they on circulation it would make less
frequent the choking Zand other pains
from which he suffered the size in the
life of complete inertia that she had
led that she led she attached to the
least of her sensations and
extraordinary importance endowed them
with a motility that made it difficult
for her to keep them secret and failing
a confidant confidant to whom she might
communicate them she used to announce
them to herself in an unceasing
monologue which are holes which was her
soul form of activity unfortunately
having formed the habit of thinking loud
she did not always take care to see that
there was no one in the adjoining room
and I would also hear her saying to of
herself I must not forget that I never
slept a wink for never sleeping a wink
for never sleeping a wink where is a
great claim to distinction and she
admitted and respected in our household
vocabulary in the morning transpose
would come to wake her but would simply
enter her room during the day when my
aunt wish to take a nap she used to say
just that she was to reflect or rest and
when in conversation she's so far for
God herself as to say what woke me up or
I dream that she would bless and it once
correct herself after waiting a minute I
would go in and kiss her transpose would
be making her tea or at my aunt was
feeling agitated she would ask instead
to Zane and it would be my duty to shake
out of the pharmacist little package
onto a plate the amount of lime blossom
required for infusion in boiling water
the drawing of the stems had twisted
them into a fantastic trellis and whose
interlacing the pale flowers open as
though Peter had arranged them they're
grouping them in the most decorative
poses the leaves having lost or alter
their appearance assumed those instead
of the most incongruous things the
transparent wings of flies or the black
size of labels or the petals of roses
but which would have been collected and
pounded or interwoven as Birds we the
material for their nests a thousand
trifling little details the charming
protic ality of the pharmacists details
would have been eliminated from an
artificial preparation gave me like a
book in which one is astonished to read
the name of a person who one knows the
pleasure of finding that these were
indeed the stems of real blind blossoms
like those i had seen at Avenue de
llegar altered precisely because they
were not imitations but the very same
blah shins that had grown old and as
each new characters merely a
metamorphosis from an older character in
these little grey balls i recognized
green buds plucked before their time but
beyond else the rosy lunar and tender
glow that lit up the blossoms in the
frail forest of skins from which they
hung like little golden roses marking as
the radiance on an old wall still marks
the place of a vanished fresco the
detail between those parts the distance
the difference between those parts of
the tree that had and those that had not
been in bloom showed me that these were
petals which before their flowering time
the pharmacist package having bombed on
warm evenings of spring those
music that rosy candlelight was still
there color but haffa sting guished and
samuel a'n't and the diminished life
that was now there's that is like the
twilight of a flower presently my aunt
was able to dip in the boiling confusion
in which he would savor the taste of
dead or faded blossoms a little Madeline
of which she would hold out a piece to
me when it was sufficiently soft that
one side of her bets to the big yellow
chest of drawers of Lemonwood and a
table that served at once as pharmacy
and as high altar on which beneath the
statue of Our Lady and a bottle of e she
is Scylla Stan might be found her
missiles and her medical prescriptions
everything that she needed for the
performance in bed of her duties to soul
and body to keep the proper times for
pepsin and for vegetables on the other
side her bed was bounded by the window
she had the street beneath your eyes and
would read in it from morning light
tonight to divert the tedium of her life
like a Persian to Prince the Daily but
in memorial potables hambre but she
would discuss in detail afterwards with
French wats I would not have been five
minutes with my aunt before she would
send me away for fear I might make her
tired she would hold out for me to kiss
her sad brow pale and lifeless on which
at this early hour she would not yet
have arranged the fault here and through
which the bone shone like the points of
a crown of thorns or the beads of a
rosary and she would say to be now my
poor child you must leave you must leave
me go near ready for mass and if you see
France was downstairs tell her not to
stay too long amusing yourself with you
she must come up soon to see if I want
anything